[Música]
buenos días soy abogada me dedico a
proteger el derecho a reputación en
internet
o se han publicado alguna fotografía
vuestra en internet y alguna fotografía
vuestra digamos no muy agraciada
y si nuestro permiso
cuando tekle hais vuestro nombre en
google os gusta lo que otros dicen sobre
vosotros
en fin es legal eliminar un facebook
puede un resultado de google ser ilegal
a esto me dedico
para responder estas preguntas y exponer
la complejidad de este tema legal
voy a exponer un caso un caso real el
caso de un cliente
llamémosle winston smith y la odisea
legal que pasamos juntos
el caso del señor winston smith me llega
a mí a comienzos del 2014
en ese momento no existía ni el
reglamento general de protección de
datos europeos ni el derecho al olvido
digital ni ningún derecho digital
reconocido internacionalmente
pero hagamos un poco de historia de
internet
internet ha ido avanzando primero
avances en la tecnología luego las
personas la sociedad nos hemos ido
adaptando a estos cambios tecnológicos y
han cambiado un poco las relaciones
sociales que tenemos
y
por causas de abusos llega tarde y torpe
la ley
se entiende más o menos generalizado el
uso de internet en el año 1998 hace
apenas 21 años
es un tiempo muy reciente para el
derecho
en el 2001 se universaliza google google
cambia nuestra forma de entender
internet simplemente con la introducción
de unos términos salen estructurados
unos resultados de búsqueda
posteriormente llega a las redes
sociales facebook twitter instagram
todo esto va moldeando internet nos va
cambiando la forma en que nuestros datos
personales se exhiben en internet
en estos momentos nuestros datos
personales en internet se exhiben las 24
horas del día los 7 días de la semana
desde cualquier punto del planeta y todo
esto sin absoluto control
en el 2014 cuando me llega el señor
winston resulta que a este señor le
habían publicado un post de facebook con
su nombre su apellido su dirección una
foto suya no muy agraciada asociado a
unos comentarios
que eran el señor winston smith es
un mentiroso me ha robado todo mi dinero
mujeres cuidado
claro el señor winston smith estaba muy
preocupado porque todo era falso pero
eso no era lo peor lo peor era cuando en
google ponían su nombre y su apellido
salía como primer resultado este post de
facebook y que pasa que le impedía una
vida normal le impedía una vida digna
porque no podía encontrar un buen
trabajo no tenía clientes en su página
web
y no encontraba pareja en internet
porque no seamos ingenuos cuando
conocemos a alguien nuevo lo primero que
van a hacer va a ser poner nuestro
nombre y apellido en google y a ver qué
sale
bueno pues él
señor winston se va a la comisaría de
policía a poner una denuncia
el policía todo atónito se lo queda
mirando no mueve ni un papel
se burla de él y le dice a nosotros nos
pasa esto todos los días bueno el señor
winston smith sale de la comisaría
totalmente [ __ ] y traumatizado y va
a buscar ayuda profesional ahí es cuando
me llega a mí
bueno y me preguntaba es legal eliminar
un post de facebook
bueno la verdad es que en toda la
carrera de derecho no se estudia si es
legal eliminar un facebook no se estudia
ningún máster en ninguna conferencia
nunca se ha estudiado yo que era una
profesional de las nuevas tecnologías no
hay ningún asunto de estos tratados en
un tema legal en el 2014 bueno lo que sí
existía es una ley de protección de
datos que habla bueno pues de proteger
los datos personales y también existe un
delito internacional que se llama
difamación que es un delito en todos los
países del mundo
pero bueno yo tenía que contestar la
respuesta del cliente así que bueno
pregunta a compañeros
es legal eliminar un facebook y bueno y
encontré respuestas de todo tipo unos me
decían que no era cuestión de la ley que
la cuestión de diplomacia internacional
otros me decían que si era jurisdicción
de california y los europeos no tenían
nada que hacer bueno la verdad eso no
era una respuesta así que dije bueno
pues voy a ir a un estamento superior
voy a preguntar a un juez
señor juez es legal eliminar un facebook
el señor juez me responde que es
facebook
bueno facebook es una red social de
internet internet
qué es internet no es eso de porno
gratis
bueno pues después de esta respuesta
dije tengo que buscar una solución en
otro sitio así que me fui a la academia
y me fui a preguntar a la facultad de
derecho hay alguna profesora o profesor
especialista en derecho de internet y me
dijeron ese derecho no existe bien digo
bueno pues algún profesor que se dedique
a algo de temas de internet nuevas
tecnologías tecnologías de la
información y comunicación no sé cómo se
diga y me dijeron
hay una señora que está en una comisión
de nuevos dispositivos tecnológicos que
está ahí al fondo del pasillo es la
doctora yasser y bueno pues me fui a su
despacho y le pregunté a la doctora
yasser es legal eliminar un facebook
y ella me contestó si es legal y no sólo
es legal sino que es una responsabilidad
de cada uno
dije vale bueno pues ya por fin tenía la
respuesta de que si es dejar eliminar un
facebook pero ahora hay que ver
como llevo a cabo lo de eliminar un
facebook
bueno pues empecé a estudiar los
derechos involucrados qué derechos hay
en internet no hay una ley de internet
no hay una autoridad global de internet
no hay una policía de internet así que
me fui a la norma que es más
internacional y que se aplica en todos
los países del mundo que es la
declaración universal de derechos
humanos de 1948 que dice el artículo 1
de la declaración universal de derechos
humanos todas las personas tienen
derecho a una vida digna
el artículo 12 dice todas las personas
tienen derecho al honor y a la
reputación y el artículo 22 dice todas
las personas tienen derecho al libre
desarrollo de su personalidad en cada
etapa de su vida
bueno ya tenía más o menos los derechos
internacionales involucrados
pero luego hay que delimitar la
responsabilidad quién es responsable
quién tiene la tecnología para eliminar
un facebook
pues facebook
así que dije bueno pues voy a contactar
con facebook en pc luego voy a buscar un
email de contacto no hay ningún email de
contacto
únicamente una dirección física de
california y dije bueno pues voy a
escribir una carta a facebook una carta
de correo ordinario de esos consejos y
todo bueno entonces voy y le envió una
carta a facebook
y luego como al final lo que más le
molestaba al señor winston smith era que
saliese como el primer resultado ese
post de en google y digo bueno pues veía
también a contactar con google
ningún email de contacto y si una
dirección física de california viva
bueno pues voy a escribir un correo
ordinario también de estos contrario y
todo a california al cabo de 15 días
recibo un sobre enorme de google lo
hablo lo abro un solo folio con una
frase
este no es el canal de comunicación con
google
bueno de facebook nunca recibí ninguna
carta
bueno llegados a este punto sabéis
cuántos contenidos se publican cada
minuto en internet
4.500.000 búsquedas de google
al minuto 277.000 stories de instagram
188 millones de emails cada minuto hacer
las cuentas cuántos contenidos hay cada
día y sabéis que algunos de estos
contenidos pueden ir sobre ti sobre ti o
sobre ti
algunos van a ser positivos pero algunos
van a ser negativos
y algunos aunque sean positivos no
representan el estado vital en el que os
encontráis actualmente
lo que quiero decir es que todos tenemos
el poder de decidir qué información
sobre nosotros se visualiza en internet
todos tenemos
qué es ser conscientes que no debemos de
soportar informaciones negativas en
internet sobre nosotros
desde el 2018 ha entrado en
obligatoriedad en europa el reglamento
general de protección de datos
personales que prohíbe la publicación de
datos personales sin consentimiento
cuyas infracciones se sancionan con
multas de hasta 20 millones de euros en
los cinco continentes hay numerosas
leyes de protección de datos personales
existen los derechos y hay que
ejercerlos
bueno al final lo que os quiero decir es
dejad cosas bonitas en internet porque
al final va a ser la historia y el
recuerdo que quede sobre nosotros
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]